en polonia cerca de la frontera
bielorrusa un grupo de sirios consiguió
salir de la zona restringida
unos voluntarios polacos les brindan
ayuda cómo se sienten tengo demasiado
frío tienes frío tienes comida o agua no
hay seis adultos y un niño estos
colchones los necesitan dicen que han
sido rechazados varias veces por los
guardias fronterizos de polonia
intentamos volver a nuestro país porque
ya sabes no podíamos cruzar la frontera
pero cuando intentamos volver a ming el
ejército bielorruso nos atrapó y algunos
fuimos golpeados puede contarnos un poco
más sobre lo que ocurrió donde lo
atraparon que hicieron en el lado polaco
vale he intentado cruzar la frontera
nueve veces también un coche
este grupo no quiere ser visto y otro
toma sus datos por si acaso
si la policía nos atrapa te llamamos así
puede llamarnos pero aunque los
voluntarios pueden ayudar con asistencia
jurídica y alimentos no pueden ofrecer
mucha esperanza
le seré sincero tenemos muchos grupos
que son rechazados así que estos sirios
no van a pedir auxilio sino a probar
suerte en el bosque adiós de vuelta a
varsovia y otro confiesa su
desesperación por ver las autoridades
polacas devolver a todos estos migrantes
al bosque helado
quieren que la gente muera para
desanimar a los demás y esto no sólo es
ilegal sino que también es inhumano no
debería ocurrir en europa y
especialmente en polonia
pero no muy lejos de la frontera en su
corte a muchos residentes apoyan la
línea dura del gobierno ver a los
migrantes como una amenaza nos van a
matar ya han robado un coche allí cuando
voy al campo me da miedo dormir en el
pueblo cerca de la frontera si les
dejamos entrar vendrán cientos de miles
más si polonia lo hace la ola no solo se
extenderá al país sino a toda la unión
europea ya vimos lo que pasó en 2015
mientras tanto es imposible saber
cuántos migrantes se esconden en estos
bosques o cuántos han muerto